frédéric rivière vous recevez ce avant l
aérés la secrétaire d'état chargée de la
jeunesse et de l'engagement bonjour
sarraï avait bonjour le parlement a
adopté définitivement cette nuit le
projet de loi qui prévoit l'obligation
vaccinale mans les soignants et un
certain nombre d'autres professions
ainsi que l'extension du pass sanitaires
un compromis a donc été trouvé entre la
majorité présidentielle de l'assemblée
nationale et la droite qui domine le
sénat la version finale du texte ou par
est elle satisfaisante et peut-être en
particulier pour les jeunes qui sont au
coeur de votre mission
très sincèrement oui moi je me félicite
de cet accord au delà des évolutions de
mesures ce qui était absolument importés
sont pas assez nombreuses et fall bien
oui ils sont nombreux et ça veut dire
que le travail a été a été intense vous
savez avant de rejoindre le gouvernement
il ya un an
aujourd'hui jour pour jour j'étais
député et ses députés donc je sais j'ai
l'assemblée nationale et sur des textes
aussi important que l'élargissement du
pas salutaire que des ordonnances
sanitaires on ne peut pas par
chicaneries politique crée la fracture
ou la fragmentation est là parce qu'il
ya un accord qui a été trouvé entre le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale eh bien
les évolutions elles touchent les jeunes
d'abord avec l'extension par exemple
jusqu'au 30 septembre du pass pour les
12 17 ans que la maison en effet tout à
fait on a également un certain nombre
d'évolutions comme le contrôle du fait
de s'isoler quand on a été contaminé
positif en passant par les forces de
l'ordre jeu à la place des forces de
l'ordre c'est maintenant la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie et au delà
de ça le fait de maintenir quand même le
pass and i ter sur les terrasses enfin
moi ce que je vois c'est que la
représentation nationale qui représente
en réalité peuple français à trouver les
voies et moyens pour surtout ne pas se
tromper d'ennemi
notre seul et unique ennemi reste le
virus puisque vous avez parlé des
terrasses le sénat souhaitait dans les
propositions qui avaient été faites
souhaitait limiter le patiani terre aux
lieux intérieurs confiné donc il
n'aurait pas eu besoin pour accéder aux
terrasses compte tenu de ce que l'on
cède ce que nous répète quand même
maintenant depuis de très longs mois sur
la transmission du virus en extérieur
est ce que cette mesure n'était pas
cohérente c'est le fait de maintenir le
pass annie terre pour les terrasses
c'est une mesure qui est nécessaire dans
le sens où il ya une concentration de
personnes
le même lieu et dans le même espace
tactile destinée plutôt à rendre un peu
la vie moins marrante à ce qu'ils ont
pas vaccinés et de leur dire allez vous
faire vacciner si vous pouvez compter
mais si vous voulez continuer à profiter
des petits plaisirs de la vie
vous savez je crois que les libertés
engage des responsabilités et il faut
être extrêmement clair avec ça choisir
choisir sa vie choisir de se faire
vacciner ou pas c'est décidé et de fait
c'est aussi décider si on choisit les
loisirs
le fait d'aller au cinéma d'aller au
restaurant de ne pas le faire et à ce
moment là de passer avec ce nom mais il
faut pas se tromper c'est pas l'un et
l'autre aujourd'hui la responsabilité
deux du gouvernement la responsabilité
de notre pays ce que font les soignants
c'est d'abord et avant tout lutter
contre ce virus et ses conséquences donc
là la liberté de se vacciner ou pas
reste évidemment pour chaque français
c'est le choix qui a été fait par le
président de la république mais la
liberté c'est aussi d'accepter un moment
s'ils ont choisi de ne pas se vacciner
et bien de voir ses loisirs restreint
mais manuel mag on apprenait en quelque
sorte ctm a dit hier ce n'est pas la
liberté de ne pas se faire vacciner
c'est des responsabilités c'est
l'égoïsme
vous trouvez que c'est le rôle du
président n'a recueilli que dire ça il
n'aurait pas chercher peut-être être
plutôt un peu dans l'apaisement plus tôt
peut-être d'ostraciser des gens qui sont
sceptiques ou récalcitrants pour des
raisons variées mais que peut-être là
ils risquent de radicaliser au lieu de
les ramener vont tuer le mans vers la
vaccination c'est parce que moi ce que
je vois c'est plusieurs millions de
français qui vont vers les centres de
vaccination est d'ailleurs des très
jeunes en fait des très jeunes ceux qui
avaient entre 18 et 35 ans et qui
doutait ya à peine quelques mois moi ce
que je vois c'est des pays entiers qui
cherche le virus est à peine ya quelques
ya à peine ya quelques quelques semaines
de ça et quelques mois on rêvait tous de
retrouver une vie normale et en fait on
rêvait de quoi on rêvait de ce vaccin
aujourd'hui qu'il y ait plusieurs
millions de personnes qui ne souhaitent
la save avait plus de la disparition des
risques du vaccin pour lutter contre
quelque chose d'utile qu'il faut juger
pour la vie normale ça y'a pas de doute
aujourd'hui la seule la salle voit qu'on
a trouvé réellement pour sortir le plus
vite possible de cette période et de
cette crise sanitaire c'est le vaccin
maintenant est ce que oui ou non il faut
dire les choses
je crois que cette quatrième vague et la
veine de ceux qui ne souhaitent pas sans
actionner et pas comme on a pu
l'entendre ici ou là la vague des jeunes
ce n'est pas vrai je suis là mouvement
très large de vaccination chez les
jeunes une volonté 2 et ceux qui doutent
moi je le comprends mais je les appelle
à discuter d'aller dans les centres de
vaccination discute avec solistes sont
fait vacciner ou plus largement plus
largement
juste avec les médecins est ce qu'on
peut s'interroger sur la cohérence qui
lie à imposer un pass and hétérogène
dans leur vie quotidienne par exemple
donc à partir du 1er octobre finalement
pour aller boire un verre sur une
terrasse alors qu'il n'y aura pas de
passe à des terres dont les
établissements scolaires quand même
il ya beaucoup de monde et ça brasse le
tas sanitaire au sein d'établissements
scolaires n'est pas n'est pas prévu pour
une raison toute simple c'est que les
protocoles que nous avons tenues avec
jean michel blanquer qui ont évolué
étape par étape
ils sont hyper hyper restrictif en
réalité il ya très peu de brassage ni
dans les cantines ni dans les salles de
classe et salles de classe ont très
largement aérer les élèves restent assis
donc ce n'est pas des espaces comme les
autres est d'autant plus que nous avons
cette fierté cette fierté française
d'avoir permis l'éducation pour tous
d'avoir gardé nos écoles ouvertes parce
qu'on ne peut pas et bien laisser des
inégalités se creusent et des inégalités
d'accès à l'éducation c'est pour ça que
les écoles aujourd'hui ne sont pas
imposées par le passé militaire
vous avez transmis il ya quelques jours
une note au président de la république
sur l'abstention chez les jeunes
d'abstention a atteint des sommets lors
des récentes élections régionales un peu
plus de 65% plan général et environ 85 %
chez les 18 34 ans pour comprendre et
ont tenté d'apporter des réponses
vous avez organisé dans quelques jours
un colloque avec des chercheurs des
représentants dagenais syndicales
politiques et associatives
qu'est-ce qu'il est sorti de ce travail
une volonté collective d'un sursaut d'un
sursaut républicain d'un sursaut
démocratique et pour être très concise
mais pour les droites au but le fait de
se retrouver autour de la table avec
plusieurs mouvements politiques allant
de la france des jeunes de la france en
soumises jusqu'au jeune la chronique en
passant par les démocrates les
centristes plus largement les
socialistes c'est de se dire que non
l'abstention n'est pas condamnée à la
vie à la vivre à la subir année après
année
absolument pas 1 ce n'est pas une
réalité 2 les réponses pour lutter
contre l'abstention des jeunes doivent
être collectives un peu comme le vote de
se passer ni terres ni général et il
faut essayer plusieurs choses sont
sorties de la crise et par exemple donc
dans votre alors il ya trois grands
pôles d'abord lutter contre cette phrase
ça ne sert à rien et donc c'est comment
plus de plus d'action directe plus
d'évolution la contamination du vote
blanc à la question du vote à 16 ans est
ce qu'on nous risquons nous pas ce qu'on
en débat la question de la
proportionnelle bien sûr comment
moderniser notre manière de voter
le vote électronique le vote à distance
comment permettre aux jeunes sur les
campus
faire des procurations s'inscrire sur
liste électorale comment retrouver son
bureau de vote
comment moderniser la propagande
électorale j'ai envie de vous dire ces
jeunes il avait il ne manquait pas
d'idées
et en plus il y avait des consensus et à
vitesse vote que finalement la façon de
susciter leur intérêt qu'il faudrait
améliorer alors en réalité il ya trois
points l'intérêt vous avez raison les
modalités de vote c'était le deuxième
point est le troisième c'était quand
même un parcours de citoyenneté avec
jean-michel blancarde et dès le plus
jeune âge on va les td les éco-délégués
la démocratie scolaire
il faut renforcer l'éducation morale et
civique
l'apprentissage de nos institutions et
c'est ce que nous faisons avec la mise
la prise en compte du vote blanc une
très vieille revendication vous pourriez
vous la soutenir
moi je suis et j'ai depuis longtemps été
favorables effectivement la
comptabilisation du vote blanc parce que
je pense qu'il ya une vraie différentes
bré différence entre celui qui se
déplace dans un bureau de vote et qui
met un bulletin de vote glissés wifi qui
ne se reconnaît en personne exactement
qui le sanctionne
celui qui ne se déplace pas du tout
merci sarah la grille bonne journée
merci bonne journée